هل تشعر بالقلق اذا ما نسيت اخذ هاتفك
الجوال معك هل تصاب بالضيق او التوتر اذا
منقطع الانترنت عنك اذا كان جوابك نعم فقد
تكون مصابا برهاب الابتعاد عن الهاتف او
ما يعرف اليوم في الطب النفسي باسم وهو
اختصار لعباره
بالانجليزيه من اعراضه الاستفزاز بسرعه
والتعرق وانعدام التركيز بالاضافه الى
تغير نمط التنفس وزياده في سرعه دقات
القلب بحسب الخبراء يكون بعض الاشخاص اكثر
عرضه للاصابه بالنوم فوبيا من غيرهم ولا
سيما من يعانون القلق او قله الثقه بالنفس
او صعوبه في تنظيم الاحساس ونمطا غير صحي
بالتعلق
المراهقون من اكثر الفئات العمريه المهدده
اذ ينظرون الى هواتفهم على انها بمنزله
حواسيبهم المصغره فيصبحون بمرور الوقت غير
قادرين على تحرك خطوه من دونها لكن لحسن
الحظ يمكن التخلص من ادمان الهواتف وذلك
بتخصيص مساحه للاسترخاء دون الاستعانه
بالهواتف ويكون ذلك بالابتعاد ساعه على
الاقل في البدايه وترك الهاتف في المنزل
عند الذهاب الى الخارج والاستعانه بساعه
اليد بدلا من ساعه الهاتف والانشغال
بهوايات جديده تساعد على الاستغناء عن
الهاتف مثل مشاهده الرياضه او ممارستها او
كل من لغه جديده او القراءه
[موسيقى]